So I spent the last year with
these keyboards, and since they gave me
a very different experience,
I wanted to share my thoughts on
how to pick the right keyboard
and how the right keyboard
can have a considerable impact
on your productivity and comfort.
Hey guys.
My name is Dami and I'm an architect
and YouTuber from Vancouver, B.C.
and I type a lot.
And today, with the help of my assistants,
I want to show you which keyboard
could be the right fit for you.
This video sponsored by Shortform.
More on them later in this video.
Times have changed.
In the past,
a keyboard was an essential peripheral
before the mouse in UI were invented.
There were no other ways
to communicate with the computer.
So that means no keyboard, no party.
I don't even need a fancy keyboard.
Who cares what colors anything?
Who cares about the switches?
Shut up.
But nowadays, the experience of buying
a keyboard is a really tailored
experience, and the level of esthetic
customization and tech and comfort options
can be a little bit overwhelming.
So I chose these three keyboards
because they provide a very diverse
experience and they're based on different
typing technologies.
We've got the $10 wired membrane keyboard.
I'm sure it works fine.
The fully mechanical wireless Nuphy Air75.
The HP 975 dual mode.
Also wireless. Perfectly appropriate.
Let's start with the generic wired
keyboard.
This is one of the cheapest models
I was able to find on Amazon
and it costs approximately $10 USD.
And you know what?
It actually friggin works
like there is zero setup time, there's
no pairing and you don't have to worry
about charging the batteries.
This version even has a small power button
that can turn
on your desktop computer,
and it's also got two risers.
All you need to do is plug the USB cable
and you're pretty much good to go.
And even as the most basic keyboard,
as you'll see compared to other models,
this one even has a light indicator
that shows
whether tap logs or other function are on.
See, I told you, you don't need
to spend money on a keyboard,
but although it gets the job
done, you are left with the bare minimum
in terms of comfort and portability.
The whole experience of typing on this
keyboard, it does feel very plasticky
and there's a lot of rattle coming from it
and it's also quite loud.
If you need to connect this to a
laptop device, you will need to sacrifice
a USB port
and possibly use a type-c adapter.
And of course, you can't connected
via Bluetooth to portable devices.
Why isn't it working anymore?
Oh stupid keyboard.
Sorry, I think I got distracted
idiots.
And I know that the sound
might not seem like a big deal,
but when you're in a working situation
and you're working around other people
and you're working long hours, especially
in stressful situations, that is sound.
It can get kind of irritating,
especially if it's coming from
someone who's sitting right next to you.
And this might seem kind of like
a minor detail, but the way that the space
that you're working in is configured,
like maybe the size of the room,
that can all have an impact on
the reverberation of the keyboard sound.
Okay. Let's talk about these two now.
This low fi playlist is amazing.
I'm ready.
These two keyboards
have one thing in common.
They're both wireless,
and they both offer a lot of different
functionalities and connectivity options.
You can connect via Bluetooth, two point
4G wireless and even a standard USB.
The Nuphy Air75
allows up to four wireless connections
at the same time, which means you can
switch between different devices
pretty seamlessly
by using a keyboard shortcut.
The HP 975 offers
three wireless connections,
two with Bluetooth
and one with a wireless dongle.
There's a dedicated button
with light indicators
to show you
which connection is currently active,
and both of these keyboards
also offer a USB type-c port.
This is really great in situations
where you don't want to risk
having any delay or connectivity issues.
For example,
if you're working with a client
or if you're doing a presentation,
the wired option
gives you the peace of mind
so you don't really have to worry
about battery or responsiveness.
Does it mean better response
time for gaming?
Oh, my God.
Oh, yes, of course.
Okay, that's how a break
as an architect
and now a YouTuber, I'm
always trying to absorb new information.
I don't always have enough time
to sit down and read a full length book.
Short form has been great with that.
Short form gives you super high quality
guides to nonfiction books
and their team of professional writers
synthesize the information
into a single page
with very clear and concise explanations.
They also have more in-depth guides
that analyze how it compares
to other commonly accepted ideas
for certain books.
That's had a very big impact in my life.
For example,
getting things done by David Island.
I like to read the short form summaries
from time to time because your memory
just isn't perfect and you will lose
that information over time.
Now, obviously, short format
is not a substitute
for reading a full book,
but you'd be surprised how many times
I've been tricked into reading a full book
that really could have been a one pager.
So nowadays,
every time I get interested in a book,
I make sure to go into short form
and read the guides first, just
so that I know if it's going to be worth
the investment of my time.
Also, they have a great app
and one of my favorite features
is their audio library,
which they're constantly updating,
which means I can go for a run
and within like 30 minutes to an hour,
I can get pretty much all the lessons
that I need to from a book,
which is awesome.
Short form is one of those essential
apps on my phone
that help me accelerate my growth
and learning by joining through the link.
Short form dot com slash Sammy Lee you'll
receive five days of unlimited access
and an additional 20% discount
off the annual subscription,
which is going to give you access
to thousands of book guides
for the price of just one book a month.
Go check it out.
But how
does it
actually feel to type on these keyboards?
Oh, my God.
I feel like I'm entering a new world.
I feel sharp
and focused like a razor blade.
The new feature,
75, is a fully mechanical keyboard
and when you get to the purchasing window,
you can actually choose
between the different types of switches.
You can choose between linear,
tactile and clicky.
I chose the radical linear switch.
It should be quieter than the tactile
and the clicky switches, but I have to say
it is louder
compared to the HP 975 and other keyboards
that I've tried
when I type with a mechanical keyboard.
I feel a kind of deeper connection
to what I'm doing.
Let me explain.
It almost seems like
hearing some of that sound is,
first of all, really satisfying.
But when I press the keys,
it makes me want to write more.
What I'm writing is really hard
for me to get into the zone.
And this haptic experience
of the keyboard,
it makes this a little bit more pleasant.
And I can kind of only compare this
to maybe the experience
of writing with a fountain pen
where you can really feel the drag
and the sound of the pen
scratching the paper.
And it's just a totally different
experience from writing with the ball pen.
For me, these haptic experiences stimulate
a part of the brain
that help with the thinking process.
In some ways, it feels almost like
a tangible extraction of my thoughts.
And so when you start
using this mechanical keyboard,
I'm pretty sure you're going to be hooked,
not just for doing creative work
or for doing research
or filling out forms, or even leaving
bad comments on YouTube videos.
Typing on the new
fee is an extremely haptic experience.
The RGB lights the interact
with your typing movements,
and especially when I'm typing at night
in low light conditions,
this just totally elevates
my working experience.
It really feels like you're becoming one
with the document.
What the hell are you doing?
Mechanical keyboards
offer a lot of customization,
so you can really choose
the one that suits you the best.
There's a lot to talk about here, so all
I can say without making a 30 minute video
is that Anafi gave me the most engaging
and send dual typing experience
compared to these other models
for both the new fee and the HP 975.
There's power
switches on the side of the keyboard
and the new fee also has a switch
that switches between Mac and Windows.
The HP 975 has scissor switches
and produces a much quieter
clicky kind of sound.
People working close to
you will barely notice your typing,
and it's also very smooth
and a comfortable experience.
The biggest difference
between the two is definitely
the travel distance of the keys.
Pushing a scissor switch
almost feels effortless compared
to the fully mechanical keyboard.
But for me, pushing a mechanical keyboard
is still a little bit more rewarding.
So I've been using these two keyboards
for almost a year now
and they're both really great on different
tasks and situations
and also on your typing skills.
The HP 975 is sleek and silent,
and if you are someone who needs to look
at the keys to type, it's really great
for working in low light conditions.
The keycaps are optimized
for being backlit, so you can actually see
the lettering in the dark.
Another cool thing
it's got a proximity sensor
that turns on the backlight
when your hands are approaching the keys.
On the other hand, the RGV lights on.
The new features are mostly decorative.
They don't really improve the readability
in low light conditions
as long as you're
using nontransparent keycaps.
And for me, it's not really a big deal
because I usually type using muscle memory.
But for those of you
who need to look at the keys to type,
this might be a bit of an issue.
The biggest difference
in terms of ergonomic mix is probably
the positioning of the Arrow Keys
and the full sized numpad on the right,
which comes in really handy for me when
I'm doing calculations or spreadsheets,
having a dedicated spot for the arrow keys
makes it easier to find,
and it's better when you're reviewing
long documents or working with cells.
And of course, for gaming.
I don't find the arrows.
The arrows find me clear and obvious
just where I like my arrows.
The Nuphy Air 75 instead
has a much more compact
and portable design.
It's optimized more
for improving the typing experience
for laptop, keyboards
and other smaller devices.
It's got a premium aluminum body
and a set of special rubber feet
that lets you overlay it
on top of your laptop without interfering
with the keys underneath.
There's an optional sleeve
that you can use, both
as a protective case and as a stand
for tablets and smartphones.
This is great when you're traveling
and if you have to type
for an extended period of time
on small devices.
The HP 975 seems better as a replacement
for a desk keyboard
since it's considerably longer
and it's got a more professional look.
I love that it has a lot of function keys
that you can customize through the app.
Battery
life is pretty good on both devices,
but it could really vary
based on your usage.
For example,
if you use it with your backlight
all the time, it could drain the battery
a little bit faster.
But for me, I haven't charged it for weeks
and it seems like it's still going.
Trying to decide on a
$100 plus keyboard may seem
like a first world problem, but it is true
that a keyboard is something that we use
for 8 hours a day, almost every day.
And so having one that suits our needs
and makes the typing experience
more pleasant
is definitely not just a luxury, but
it is an investment that you should take
some time to consider.
For me, there's no clear winner.
I'm constantly switching
between them based on
whether I'm doing creative work
or traveling or office work.
Let me know in the comments
what type of keyboard you use.
Also, I have some great content about
architecture and design and creativity.
I'll leave a playlist right here,
and with that
I'll see you guys in the next video.
Not really me for this.
Can you repeat that?
Can you please be quiet?
I'm trying to focus here.
PDF me. What?
What do you mean? PDF me?
Nobody. PDFs me.
Don't you dare say you're going to pdf me.